alain boublil démissionne et contre
attaque le directeur de cabinet de
monsieur bérégovoy attaque en
diffamation trois journaux à propos de
la sphère pechiney george bush a prêté
serment il est le nouveau président
américain d réunis face à washington
pour le 41e saison
le ski français relève la tête les
françaises plus tôt
carole merle crayon une nouvelle fois à
tignes elle redonne le moral aux autres
au tableau d'honneur de jeunes du monde
agricole il participe à une grande
opération de solidarité en faveur des
déshérités
bonsoir le tournant dans l'affairé chine
et alain boublil directeur du cabinet du
ministre de l'économie pierre bérégovoy
alain boublil a démissionné et ils
contre attaquent maintenant il va
poursuivre trois journaux en diffamation
souvent montrés du doigt monsieur
boublil veut se disculper dès hier soir
son ministre avait annoncé qu'il allait
le faire
résumé de cette journée décisive claire
chazal françoise joly 8 heures ce matin
alain boublil quitte son domicile
il se rend pour la dernière fois au
ministère des finances en poche sa
lettre de démission qu'il transmet
quelques heures plus tard au ministre
pierre bérégovoy
depuis plusieurs semaines une campagne
de rumeurs et d'accusations 1 mais
gravement en cause sans que je puisse y
répondre en raison des exigences de
réserves inhérentes à ma fonction c'est
pourquoi afin de riposter aux
accusateurs
je vous prie de bien vouloir accepter ma
démission
le nom d'alain boublil apparaît en effet
depuis plus d'un mois dans ce que l'on
appelle très vite la sphère pechiney
cette affaire révélée par la presse et
le scandale financier qui entoure le
rachat par péchiney de la société
américaine american can
juste avant l'accord officiel des
personnes trop bien informées achète à
new york plus de 200000 titre elles
réalistes ainsi de confortables
bénéfices selon les enquêteurs
américains il ya eu délit
initier les acheteurs auraient été
renseignées par les négociateurs directe
de l'accord
parmi ces négociateurs bien sûr alain
boublil
rien d'étonnant à cela pechiney est une
entreprise publique à la double il ne
fait que remplir ses fonctions et suit
donc pas à pas les discussions mais
voilà il entretient des relations
privilégiées avec un autre négociateur
côté américain samir traboulsi homme
d'affaires libanais au train de vie de
milliardaire et aux amitiés politiques
sans exclusive alain boublil s'est déjà
défendu devant la cob le 12 janvier
dernier et souhaite d'ailleurs que son
entretien soit rendue publique
ce soir il contre attaque et porte
plainte contre trois journaux oui pour
l'instant la démission de monsieur
boublil n'apporte pas d'éléments
vraiment nouveau à lenquête et dossiers
restent en l'état il faudra encore
attendre
il n'empêche les projecteurs de
l'actualité sont soudain braquer sur un
homme de l'ombre un de ces
fonctionnaires qui vivent dans le
sillage des ministres eh bien cette fois
le faisceau du projecteur s'est décalé
portrait d'alain boublil jean-pierre
motivé mais 88 pierre bérégovoy revient
aux finances
derrière lui son nouveau directeur de
cabinet alain boublil un inconnu pour le
grand public
en fait une éminence grise un conseiller
qui a gravit lentement les échelons du
pouvoir
dès 1981 il entre à l'elysée que le
conseiller technique de françois
mitterrand chargé des affaires
industrielles
c'est un proche de jacques nathalie à
l'elysée alain boublil traite des
dossiers que 2000 chaud comme boussac et
acquiert une réputation celle d'un homme
autoritaire il se fait des inimitiés
jean pierre chevènement dit-on et roger
fauroux alors patron de saint gobain
mais on le dit en bon terme avec georges
pébereau l'homme qui vient de tenter un
raid sur la société générale
dans ce raid on verra la main d'alain
boublil qui vient d'arriver aux finances
avec un dossier essentiel s'attaquer au
noyau dur des sociétés privatisées par
l'ancien ministre de l'économie
edouard balladur pour alain boublil qui
n'appartient ni à l'ena ni à
l'inspection des finances c'était
l'occasion de ne pas se faire que des
amis
voilà pour l'homme nous avons vu juste
avant les faits alors maintenant
philippe sassier qu'est ce qui va se
passer
il ya trois étapes d'abord où l'attend
la publication de ce que a
boublil a déclaré à l'ats coop pour
l'instant alain bauguil que nous avons
joint à plusieurs reprises aujourd'hui
au téléphone ainsi que ses avocats
refusent de parler
deuxièmement jeudi puis avec voix le
ministre des finances sera devant la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
où il sera entendu par les
parlementaires n'en apprendra peut-être
un tout petit peu plus enfin
troisièmement c'est le bouquet c'est la
troisième étape la plus importante
la cob la commission des opérations de
bourse femme gendarme montre vous parle
depuis déjà plusieurs jours va remettre
son rapport
dès la fin du mois deux réponses qui
sont attendus
qui est ce qui se cache derrière les
banques suisses luxembourgeoise ou bien
celles qui sont en guyane dont on a
parlé et est-ce qu'on ira jusqu'au bout
est ce que la cote sera faire son métier
aussi bien que l'a fait jusqu'à présent
sa collègue américaine l'aes ici
philippe c est ce que vous avez le
sentiment aujourd'hui que la démission
de monsieur boublil finalement à
débloquer le dossier
non mais vous non plus là parce que la
démission d'alain boublil aborde sa de
prouver qu'ils m'ont pas sa culpabilité
on est un petit peu trop confondues ces
temps ci les rumeurs et les preuves il
ya deux grandes questions qui restent
toujours posé un qui est le véritable
informateur qui est qu'est-ce qui se
cache l'air les informations qui ont
permis ces opérations
deuxième question qui sont tous les
acheteurs on en connaît 4 vous le savez
il ya tous ces totalités à l'étranger
plus de 150 pays qui ont été achetées à
l'étranger il sera très difficile il ne
faut pas se farder la vérité de
connaître sinon mais ça c'est
véritablement le gros problème en tout
cas philippe ce qui est sûr c'est que
dans tous les milieux politiques tous
les milieux politiques ce soir sont dans
l'expectative
il y a très peu de réactions de ce côté
là comme si à gauche comme à droite on
avait décidé de mettre une sourdine
seule exception cette déclaration
d'alain juppé pour le rpr il s'inquiète
de voir les socialistes utilisé la
technique du fusible
il n'empêche philippe il y aura
forcément des remous politiques
d'ailleurs valoir des remous politiques
dont il est encore difficile de savoir
jusqu'où ils pourront aller remous
politiques en france comme aux
politiques à l'étranger en tout cas un
mois et demi des municipales c'est vrai
hervé ça n'est pas très bon pour
l'actuelle majorité mais on est très
prudent un peu partout vous venez de le
dire parce que toutes ces rumeurs autour
de la france autour de la bourse de
paris font que cela déclenche une série
de papiers assez sévère dans des
journaux très sérieux le financial times
et le wall street journal américain et
que par conséquent les partis politiques
sans qu'il ne serait pas très très bon
de déclencher de bataille à coups de
scandale ce que l'on peut dire
aujourd'hui c'est que tout le monde
semble souhaiter que le voeu de monsieur
bérégovoy célérité et vérités soient
respectés donc le maximum de la vérité
sorte et rapidement pour que on s'occupe
enfin autre chose et tous les français
le souhaitent aussi merci philippe les
etats-unis ont un nouveau président
george bush depuis deux heures à peine
il est devenu le 41e président des états
unis
il a prêté serment depuis mercredi et
pendant cinq jours les états unis
célèbrent l'événement en même temps que
le bicentenaire du premier président
américain il s'appelait george
washington solennité émotions faste
jacquat bouchard à washington
la foule les touristes les marchands de
souvenirs ont convergé de bonheur aux
abords du capitole le siège du congrès
pour la cérémonie officielle
d'investiture du président élu journée
de fête agrémentée par un temps
printanier george bush est arrivé après
avoir assisté à un service religieux en
compagnie de son épouse barbara et du
vice-président dan quare prestation de
serment devant le président de la cour
suprême en s'engageant sur la bible à
défendre la constitution george bush est
devenu le 41e président des états unis
deux cents ans après le père fondateur
george washington
une cérémonie brève suivie par une salve
d'honneur de 21 coups de canon puis dans
son premier discours de chef d'état
george bush en a appelé à l'unité et à
la générosité de ses compatriotes
enfin c'était l'ultime tête à tête entre
ronald reagan
avant son départ pour la californie est
l'homme qui fut pendant huit ans son
fidèle second à la maison blanche
malgré la solennité de l'événement le
business marche très fort les
organisateurs ont vendu 140 mille
billets pour les cérémonies ici au
capitole et pour la parade
budget de l'opération 150 millions de
francs un record absolu
l'afer a été menée comme une super
production hollywoodienne et ce
catalogue édité spécialement pour la
circonstance contient tous les détails
du programme
il est intitulé élections
présidentielles du bicentenaire 1789
1989 aux côtés de george bush vous
l'avez certainement déjà vu sa femme
barbara en un dîner hier soir elle s'est
acquis les faveurs de tout le peuple
américain cette femme que l'on disait un
peu alger mal habillé un peu bobo no 6
et bien elle a retourné l'opinion en
quelques phrases beaucoup de classe et
beaucoup de métier écoutez cet étonnant
michel mompontet une maîtresse de
cérémonie très hollywoodienne marilyn
quell la femme du vice-président jeune
belle 41 ans est la star hier soir ce
n'était pas elle s'était barbara bush
soixante trois ans des cheveux blancs
des rides un sourire de grand mère et un
manque d'intérêt pour les toilettes
qu'elle avoue volontiers la presse
américaine n'avait pas manqué de
souligner ce qu'elle considérait comme
des tares mais voilà cette grand mère
sait aussi sortir quand il faut samhain
chester mais avec le sourire bien
entendu
pendant que les jeunes
freddy d'industrie
moi pas
rendu à ce niveau
elle est même
plutôt qu'être la first lady même retapé
par des conseillers en communication
barbara elle a préféré devenir la force
mamie de tous les américains
décidément la compagnie boeing bien des
soucis il ya eu l'accident en angleterre
vous en souvenez et puis les
vérifications ensuite qui ont fait
apparaître des installations inversé ou
mal branché ce matin près de chicago un
737 a perdu un de ses réacteurs
hier aux états unis toujours à taux aux
etats unis toujours pardon atlanta cette
fois un boeing 757 a perdu un bout
d'aile
attachez vos ceintures philippe dumez
voici les débris du réacteur du boeing
737 sur la piste de l'aéroport de
chicago dans l'histoire de l'aviation
moderne c'est peut-être la deuxième fois
seulement qu'un tel incident se produit
c'est au moment du décollage que ce
biréacteur de la compagnie américaine
piémont a perdu son réacteur droit
aucun des 27 occupants de l'appareil n'a
été blessé hier un autre boeing avait
perdu plus d'un mètre carré d'un panneau
dance est donc une véritable série noire
après l'accident survenu au début du
mois en angleterre avec le même type
d'appareil défauts de construction ou
défaillance de la maintenance des boeing
les experts se pose encore la question
les passagers eux vont peut être trouvée
que l'avion n'est plus un moyen de
transport très sécurisant françois
mitterrand à bonn
le président français s'est rendu à
l'anniversaire de vibrantes tous les
grands de l'internationale socialiste
étaient présents pour célébrer l'ancien
chancelier allemand qui a dirigé
l'allemagne vous en souvenez entre 69 et
74 philippe rochot
s'il faut retenir une image des 75 ans
de vie libre et c'est sans doute celle
de l'ancien chancelier socialistes
autrichiens à bruno kreisky malade et
qui malgré ses 78 ans a tenu à honorer
l'homme qui avait marqué la politique
allemande de l'après guerre neuf chefs
d'état et de gouvernement avaient fait
le voyage pour saluer vibrante qui a osé
tenter l'ouverture à l'est et
s'agenouiller devant le monument aux
morts du ghetto de varsovie événement
exceptionnel les journalistes eux mêmes
ont voulu montrer à leur manière leur
estime pour l'ancien chancelier
socialiste brandt prix nobel de la paix
un anniversaire grandiose mais qui
permet aussi des rencontres comme celle
du chef du gouvernement polonais
rakowski avec françois mitterrand qui se
rendra en pologne l'été prochain
marquant le renforcement des liens avec
l'est tel que le veut vie libre
ça fait des années que nous sommes très
proches avec françois mitterrand nous
avons de très bons contacts à propos des
rapports est ouest et aussi de l'europe
il n'y a jamais eu autant de chance de
réaliser l'europe cas présent et dans
ces deux dimensions son ancrage à
l'ouest et ses relations avec l'ess
c'était un grand jour tombé deux fois
sur un scandale
vili brandt avait dû sortir par une
porte dérobée
ses 75 ans auront permis à l'allemagne
aux pays amis de lui rendre enfin
hommage les langues étrangères pour nos
chers petits
cette fois c'est officiel lionel jospin
a confirmé une chose qu'un ministre de
l'éducation dès la rentrée prochaine
langue est par exemple se renseigner à
l'école primaire en cm2 deux à trois
heures par semaine dans ce domaine de
l'éducation série de grèves et
manifestations le sni des instituteurs
annonce une manif le 1er février
prochain
le sni de protester contre l'absence de
revalorisation du statut d'instituteur
et puis enfin le snes le syndicat des
enseignants du secondaire annonce lui
aussi une série de grève à partir du 27
janvier prochain estimant que les
crédits annoncés par le gouvernement ne
sont pas à la hauteur des enjeux
où l'on reparle du douloureux problème
des enfants de couples mixtes franco
algérien des enfants déchirés entre
leurs deux parents entre leurs deux pays
cette semaine on a appris qu'un enfant
que son père voulait garder en algérie
et est finalement rentré en france
auprès de sa mère mais il faut savoir
que 60 cas n'ont toujours pas abouti
et ce malgré la
nature en juin dernier d'une convention
judiciaire entre la france et l'algérie
pascal deschamps dresse le bilan tout
était prêt à noël pour le retour dave
ont mené en juillet 87 en algérie par
son père à l'âge de cinq ans pendant un
an et demi
sa mère s'est battu pour qu'elle
revienne voyage en algérie grève de la
faim jusqu'au 14 novembre dernier où
après avis de la commission
un tribunal algérien confiant son droit
de garde mais deux mois plus tard rêve
n'est toujours pas là trouve ça
inadmissible que nathan que j'ai toute
la justice algérienne
de mon côté qu'on est incapable de faire
appliquer des décisions de justice
ça s'est avéré c'est inacceptable
eve a disparu avec son père lui dit on
six mois de procédure pour rien le cas
n'est hélas pas unique
pendant six ans et deux femmes se sont
battues pour qu'une convention
franco-algérienne soit signé aujourd'hui
l'heure est à la déception trop d'avis
de la commission ne sont pas suivies
d'effet si je vais faire une comparaison
simplificatrice la convention c'est
comme une voiture qui a un certain
nombre de rouages je dirais que tous les
rouages n'arrivent pas à se mettre en
marche et une mère qui doivent faire
toute la procédure qui lui a imposée par
la convention n'arrive pas à obtenir
gain de cause
georgina dufoix chargé du dossier vient
donc de convaincre les autorités
algériennes de créer un groupe d'experts
pour faire le point sur les lenteurs et
les blocages
c'est normal qu'une procédure aussi
nouvelle qui va faire école je l'espère
pour d'eau dans d'autres pays et je
l'espère en europe
c'est normal cette procédure nouvelle
demande des ajustements
ça c'est ça ça ne m'inquiète pas du tout
et c'est pas le groupe d'experts n'est
pas une façon d'enterrer les choses
d'une façon d'approfondir et de devenir
plus efficace
il y a deux ans les mères d'alger marché
vers genève pour faire entendre leur
voix
le 27 février elles y retourneront pour
dire leur déception face à un texte dans
lequel elle avait mis tous leurs espoirs
mais qui est loin d'avoir tous résolus
l'état tenté de salvador dali toujours
très grave en fait le peintre qui a 84
ans je vous le rappelle le peintre est
condamnée à très court terme il souffre
de problèmes cardiaques et d'une
infection poule même pulmonaire tous ses
amis se sont regroupés à son chevet à
figueras
mais ses médecins ont dit tout à l'heure
nous n'allons pas prolonger
et artificiellement la vie de salvador
dali c'est ce qu'a dit le directeur de
l'hôpital de figueras
il est tous les médecins souhaitent et
tous ses amis aussi qu'il est une mort
digne sans transition le sport
maintenant est d'abord le ski un
cocorico
graff a merle depuis une semaine carole
merle rafle tout cet après midi elle a
gagné le super géant de coupe du monde à
tignes et c'est tout le ski français qui
relève la tête jean ma mère le podium
apparemment nous allons devoir attire
irrésistiblement carole merle voilà
c'est parti sur les images c'était au
super-g de tinée cet après midi elle en
est à son cinquième podium consécutif et
le deuxième sur la plus haute marche car
le rhône merle c'est le ski français de
ce début de saison et il est temps elle
commence à faire des émules car
aujourd'hui car au maire n'a pas été la
seule à se mettre en avant avait quitté
5e chez dale 6e et emonet 8e le ski
français grâce à mr le commence à
siffler désormais deuxième au classement
de la coupe du monde car olmert
s'affirme chaque jour un peu plus messi
restait modeste sans papiers tout le
monde me disait favorite mais savez que
quand même une falaise père ce qui est
surtout bien reconnaître le tracé et
j'ai fait des erreurs de lyme qui aurait
pu me coûter très cher alors ça c'était
carole merle chez les françaises qui
réussissent bien et en ce moment il y en
a un autre genre ma mère qui réussit
bien mais c'est un luxembourgeois
d'adoption c'est marc girardelli raf le
tout lui il rafle tout puisque après
lastreilles c'était la descente de
kitzbühel la semaine dernière il vient
de remporter le lauberhorn la la
descente de wengen il est le septième
coureur de l'histoire à réaliser cet
exploit après des skieurs comme jean
claude killy ce n'est pas peu dire
et en est à son sixième succès de la
saison c'est remarquable
j'ai alors enfin un événement sportif
demain c'est sur antenne 2 et c'est à
dublin aussi c'est france-irlande fait
bien sûr du rugby premier match du
tournoi des cinq nations
et oui avec une ouverture difficile
commenté par pierre salviac et pierre
albaladejo une ouverture difficile
puisqu'elle est à l'extérieur à lens
drogue chez les irlandais des irlandais
qui ont besoin peu je dirais de redorer
de donner un peu de gloire à leur trèfle
un peu pâli ces derniers temps ils ont
terminé derniers la saison dernière il
avait subi une sévère défaite contre les
france au parc des princes
ils craignent les français pour leurs
nouvelles mêlées sont à l'honneur et
puis peut-être aussi trendy l'homme
appelé de la dernière heure celui qui
sera peut-être le joker j'ai cité jean
baptiste
à fond jean baptiste lafond c'est mon
joker de l'équipe de france où l'homme
le plus chanceux du monde à vous de
choisir
jean baptiste lafond c'est d'abord un
artiste un g 2 pour présenter le
dimanche en championnat
ou encore celui qui avec ses camarades
du showbiz étonne par son noeud papillon
le président mitterrand en finale du
championnat de france mais jean baptiste
lafond c'est aussi celui qui remplace
blanco blessée lors du tournoi 87 contre
l'irlande et qui pour 12 minutes de jeu
seulement devient titulaire d'un grand
chelem pour la même raison il dispute la
même saison la coupe du monde mais sur
le banc des remplaçants alors là font
appeler par les anglais eux mêmes pour
son talent dans les matchs de gala est
il de mal aimés ou bien la victime d'une
concurrence décidément trop fort tu fais
toujours des mécontents des malheureux
des frustrés des bannis des martyrs ben
moi je suis rien de tout ça je suis où
je vis ma vie et quand m'appelle c'est
bien quand on m'appelle pas c'est moins
bien mais la vie s'est fait justement de
séparation et de retrouvailles et non et
retrouva ils connaissent était au pays
de galles l'an dernier pour une victoire
dans le tournoi il est bombardé non
seulement titulaire mais en plus buteur
officielle et il fait un malheur cette
fois c'est l'irlande la victime a
remplacé c'est encore bureau et
jean-baptise accepte toujours censeurs
moi qui suis intérimaire qui fait de la
sous-traitance quand même depuis deux
ans je suis encore plus fragile que que
les autres j'ai moins de crédits que
certains et je le sais mais c'est le
challenge vous êtes un homme de
challenge tu fait vraiment marrer grâce
à vous monsieur je suis sûr demain que
nous marron encore plus
jan karski demain sur un m2 suivi je le
rappelle de la deuxième mi temps a
commenté par jean louis calmejane jean
marc et éco spéciale donc demain
après-midi une soirée une après-midi
complète de rugby merci jean les
moissons de l'espoir c'est l'objet de
notre tableau d'honneur ce soir et voici
pourquoi le ministère de l'agriculture
vient de lancer une grande opération de
solidarité
il s'agit de demander à tous les jeunes
de l'enseignement agricole de faire des
dons pour les associations caritatives
en fait pour les déshérités donné le
surplus les excédents et puis d'autres
choses aussi alors ce soir à notre
tableau d'honneur deux jeunes c'est
stéphane et sophie le soir vous
m'entendez la voir alors présenté nous
d'abord votre lit fait ou est ce que
vous êtes vous entend on vous entend
présentez-nous votre lycée d'abord
attendons oui vous entendez l'avenir
tous les patrons à la stéphane bonsoir
n'attendez sophie n'entend pas non plus
leur écoute et avant de vous présenter
on vous a vu on va enfin je vous propose
que nous voyons concrètement le type
d'opération que vous entreprenez dans
votre lit c'est justement pour aider les
associations carrick elles sont
récoltées sur la ferme du lycée des
kilos de légumes d'habitude
une partie de cette production se
retrouve dans l'assiette des internes du
lycée agricole
mais cette fois les élèves ont décidé
d'offrir poireaux et pommes de terre à
la banque alimentaire de l'oise pour les
plus démunis
c'est leur participation à cette
opération solidarité
ils ne sont pas seuls cet hiver tous les
lycées agricoles de france vont apporter
leur production aux associations
caritatives l'enseignement agricole c160
exploitation annexés aux établissements
dix mille hectares c'est à dire la plus
grande ferme de france
voilà donc ce que les jeunes du monde de
l'agriculture peuvent faire pour aider
les associations caritatives alors
j'espère je vais me retourner vers
stéphane et sophie le coeur un peu
d'attentes que cela marche et bonsoir
bonsoir copie
on vous entend qu'elle met en veille
alors on vient de voir un petit peu ce
que vous faites
expliquez-nous ce que ça vous a d'abord
présenté nous votre lycée puisque j'ai
pas pu ou voulu demander avant
dans ce lycée nous faisons la production
florale de des légumes et vous êtes à
ribécourt près d'amiens cette série b
cours il ya quelques 50 km d'amiens
secret voilà qu'est ce que vous à qu'est
ce que ça vous a apporté cette opération
stéphane ça faisait plaisir quoi de
savoir qu'on était utile à quelque chose
parce que d'habitude les légumes qu'on
mangeait une grande partie partie soit
au compost enfin aux déchets et une
autre partie était vendu puis à part ça
les fleurs les fleurs et été vendus
sophie vous avez eu l'impression que
tous les jeunes se mobilisent et c'est
d'envoi tissé par exemple s'intéresser
vraiment beaucoup les autres oui
seulement
disons que nous étions très intéressé
par par cette campagne nous nous avons
été tous mobilisés nous étions tous très
contente de faire ceci 1 pour une pour
une bonne cause
mais ça vous donne et du supplément de
travail par exemple non non non pas
vraiment c'était simplement mieux
utiliser en fait ce que vous faisiez
précédemment pour que ça serve à
quelqu'un voilà tout à fait ceci dit moi
vous savez à qui ça va aller cette aide
va aller acquis à quelle organisation
vous avez pensez vous en avez discuté
oui nous savons que ça va aller aux
restos du coeur la croix rouge sûrement
là
banque alimentaire les banques
alimentaires oui de toute façon merci
stéphane merci sophy je précise
toutefois que nous avons invité ce soir
donc vous êtes des jeunes du lycée
horticole de rivecourt mais vous n'êtes
pas les seuls vous êtes juste 2 qui
représente tout l'effort du monde
agricole notamment chez les jeunes pour
aider lé prix déshérités merci et bravo
voilà sans rapport le plus vieux livres
du monde il a été découvert il ya deux
ans en egypte bien sûr on sait tous que
c'est gutenberg qui est inventé
l'imprimerie en 1440 mais qui a inventé
livre ça on ne le sait pas c'est
beaucoup plus anciens la découverte et
l'analyse de ce livre nous dévoile vous
allez le voir quelques secrets patrick
espère 4 190 pages manuscrites des
dizaines de milliers de lettres
méticuleusement dessinée sur des
parchemins
ce livre est probablement le plus vieux
livres du monde découvert il y a deux
ans dans la tombe d'une fillette
égyptienne à 135 km au sud du caire
il est rédigé en dialecte coop une
langue morte aujourd'hui ce qui explique
qu'il faudra de nombreuses années aux
scientifiques pour traduire les psaumes
qui contient selon les archéologues qui
l'ont analysé depuis sa découverte
ce livre date du 4e siècle il a mille
six cent cinquante ans mais se trouve
dans un état de conservation
extraordinaire reliées entre deux
planchettes de bois réunis par une
charnière de plomb il préfigurait déjà
nos livres contemporain avoriaz on ne
regarde pas vers le passé si on regarde
vers le futur bien sûr moi je regarde
sur la mauvaise caméra c'est autre chose
avoriaz c'est le festival du film
fantastique est longue est là-bas
avoriaz les extraterrestres qui ne
saurait manquer d'arriver bientôt dans
ce coin perdu des alpes
et comme dans ce domaine on n'arrête pas
le progrès on a trouvé des lunettes pour
détecter ces extraterrestres pour
petites bêtes
jean jacques dufour enquêteurs
en principe les lunettes c'est important
surtout aux sports d'hiver
parce qu'avec la réverbération les
risques de conjonctivite sont grands
mais dans ses livres de john carpenteyre
ses lunettes ce modèle là permettent à
john nada n'exclut de la société
américaine ge de voir le véritable
visage d'extraterrestres qui ont ourdi
un complot contre la terre avec lunettes
et maintenant sans lunettes
d'ailleurs à avoriaz certains
festivaliers aimerait posséder ce modèle
unique et à libérer sont normales sont
désespérément normal car grâce à ses
lunettes donc le héros de john
carpenteyre va faire le ménage pour
éviter que les envahisseurs ne pas le
pouvoir
ça s'appelle séparer le bon grain de
l'ivraie
évidemment regarder la vérité en face
comme le soleil cela peut faire mal
je crois que ce serait horrible de
savoir exactement ce cas derrière le
visage des gens cedric thellier si
besoin que les gens ont maintenant deux
d'inventer des personnages extra
terrestre alors que si regarde un peu
autour d'eux ils ont tout ce qu'il faut
sous la main
oui mais cela permet de traiter plus
facilement le thème de l'étranger
d'ailleurs l'immigration et
l'intégration par le biais des
extraterrestres c'est le sujet de futur
immédiat
présenté hors compétition avoriaz
keystone six jeunes le pote matt
groening a enfin lunettes ou pas
l'essentiel c'est peut-être de regarder
avec le coeur il y à demain un tiercé
quarté + 7 à vincennes dans le prix de
granville et ya vingt partants voici les
pronostics de pierrette brès elle
propose de jouer le 8 le 11 le 19 le 15
le 9 le 10 sept
le 13 et le quatre voies la fin de ce
journal dans un instant la météo c'est
laurent cabrol je le vois ma gauche
dernière édition du journal ce sera
henri sannier vers 23h après apostrophes
et qu pour le week-end vous retrouverez
bien sûr comme d'habitude
daniel bilalian betty dureau et philippe
gassot à lundi